well hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday and it's movie time yep so uh
yeah this is a movie that I had actually
been wanting to see for a really long
time but for whatever reason we never
got around to it yeah my buddy helped on
helped make this movie yes uh we have a
friend named Brian Hackett yeah I went
to military school with him yeah
Southern California Military Academy
back in the 80s we used to hang out
together so he he ended up as a sound
guy working for Hollywood type Studios
he knows crussell and [__] friends with
crussell worked with him work with a
bunch of people and he was bugging me
man he's like man you got to see this
movie You're Gonna Love It I worked on
it and uh didn't never got around to it
we had other [__] hitting us people were
sending us DVDs and or Blu-Rays to to
review and finally it came up to where
this was available on Amazon right it's
no it was on Netflix Netflix actually
cuz I was like I know that I saw it when
I was scrolling through one of our
services that we paid for so I was like
so we should probably uh pull the
trigger on that because like I said I've
been wanting to see this like almost
since it came out yeah CU I heard about
it you know so we saw it man it was
[__] Allstar cast man a lot of
unexpected [__] stars show up I had
forgotten how star studded this cast is
Gibson's in it Don Johnson's in it yeah
Don Johnson is he's in like one scene
but yeah he's in it all kinds of people
are in it Vince vaugh is in it Jennifer
Carpenter is in it Lorie Holden uh also
known as Andrea from The Walking Dead
she's in it um you know it's they're
kind of small roles but it's a really
like an ensemble uh cast yeah yeah and
and it's it's a tight flick I liked it
kind of reminds me a little bit of a
Tarantino movie but not not as silly a
little more serious not yeah not as
stylized other people have compared it
particularly in the dialogue to um a
Tarantino flick I've also seen it
compared to like a David Fincher movie
which would be like fight club or zodiac
or something like that which this does
have kind of a Vibe like that yeah um I
will say Zach said uh I didn't finish
watching this one but I love how much of
it was shot with uh really precisely
composed wide shots yeah I really liked
uh the cinematography on this one like
the the framing the way the um the
camera was placed and stuff I will note
that if you are planning to watch this
movie it is a crime Thriller I guess I
would call it that I've also seen it
called a Neo Noir which sort of um I've
seen it compared to Cohen Brothers but
it's not a black comedy necessarily it
is kind of humorous but not really um
but I will say that this movie is very
long it's 2 hours and 40 minutes roughly
and it's pretty languidly paced let's
say it like that but but you enjoy it
though yeah but on the other
hand um I actually got quite uh involved
with it despite how there's like long
scene there's seriously like a long
scene of like Mel Gibson and Vince vaugh
like sitting in a car like doing a
Steakout and like Vince vaugh eating an
egg salad sandwich yeah and it's like a
really long scene and then like at the
end like Mel Gibson has this great line
about how like a single red ant could
have eaten the sandwich faster than he
ate it well there there's all kinds of
things about the movie that that that
like that there's a lot of just like
characterization and stuff little little
conversations that characters are having
and there's it's a bunch of different
stories and they all just kind of
converge yeah kind of like a Taran it's
structured kind of like a Tarantino
movie if you like Reservoir Dogs you'd
like this if you like Pulp Fiction you'd
like this
um what else would it compare
to um like I said I feel like it's p
it's like a Tarantino film like in the
dialogue and the structure in in the way
that it's has it's kind of like longer
and where there's like a lot of scenes
where it's just like kind of like
talking and stuff it's more like a David
fure movie like seven or something like
that yeah um it's but then it has
periods of like brutal violence and like
brutal um I don't know if you knew this
Tom but the direct writer and director
of this who is s Craig Zer this was his
third movie guess what his first movie
was what bone Tomahawk oh okay yeah so
this is the same guy that did bone
Tomahawk he also did a movie called uh
braw and cellblock 99 which I have not
seen yet but I've heard it's very good
Vince Von was also in that one playing a
completely different character to what
he plays in this um but I've heard a lot
of good about that one too so I'll
probably have to see that one as well
the movie is um a weird mixture of like
realism and the tone is kind of
realistic and then some bizarre [__]
would happen out of the
blue like Tarantino's always kind of
stylized and bizarre this one not really
it to be kind of like gritty real then
all of a sudden some bizarre character
shows up and it and and it kind of I
don't want to say it's jarring but it
kind of adds a certain weird texture to
it to it you get a little bit
discombobulated sometimes like the
French assassin guys yeah and the way
they were like is this serious you know
just yeah it was they were just weird
dudes um they'll introduce characters
just to give them a backstory cuz that's
a victim that's going to get killed off
later so you know who it was you yeah
there is one character do like this
movie came out in 2018 and maybe some
people haven't seen it so I don't want
to like spoil it spoil it but there is
one character in this that's
introduced probably like an hour and a
half into the movie yeah just out of the
blue and you're like what the [__] does
this have to do with anything and then
you find out like they're they're in it
for maybe like 10 or 20 minutes and then
they get killed they get killed yeah
like in a very so it's just so you were
kind of like what was the point of that
but um I think the point of it was I
don't know I just like the way this is
kind of like a like a tapestry yeah of
just these characters which like I said
yeah you could argue that maybe some of
it could have been cut out and it
wouldn't have mattered but I don't know
I think it added some kind of like yeah
something to it you know what I mean
yeah and this the basic story is some
foreign guys led by some weird dude like
a dress all in black he's kind of like a
something out of soldier of fortune or
something you know like old Soldier of
Fortune Magazine all black bdus and damn
black goggles you never see his face him
and three other ones think were two
other ones with ues suppressed ues they
going around killing people to save up
the money to get a uh a van like a
security van to do a heist at a bank to
steal some gold
that's what they're trying to do and
then two black guys who grew up together
one of them just got out of prison
needed
money his mom was prostituting herself
and he was trying to help her and his
little brother and he they get involved
with this Heist and go to work for these
three dudes three mysterious assassin
dudes one of them sounds French uh to do
this Heist works for him turns out
they're going to be they're going to be
killed anyway the the French guys aren't
going to let these guys live they hired
them to kill them basically they use
them as drivers and
[__] you got that going on and then you
got these two other characters who are
detectives one of them played by Mel
Gibson who was the other guy Vince vongh
Vince vaugh yeah and they're kind of
Mel's the Mel Gibson characters he's
kind of washed up he's been on the force
forever he never really got promoted
he's kind of a loser he's a cranky old
Boomer yeah he's got to move his family
out of his neighborhood cuz it's getting
bad and they're trying to harass his
daughter and [__] and uh his and his
wife has multiple sces yeah and he he
and his partner get kind of on what was
a six week suspension suspension yeah
because they roughed up a dude and
kicked him in the head at when he was
handcuffed he was like a drug dealer and
they were like arresting him yeah and
they did weird [__] during the drug bus
it's funny in not funny but it's it's
cool the [__] that they were doing
they're old school they didn't adapt
with the times and they they said we're
not going to adapt to modern times you
know [__] we're going to do it the
old school way you know like getting PE
getting naked girls wet [__] during
the arrest and putting fans on them to
make them cold to ask them where the
drugs are that kind of [__] anyway uh
they get
suspended and Mel Gibson says to his
partner they have all this equipment
that they're going to use he says he has
a lead on this gangster that's come over
who's they don't know what he's going to
do but it's the guy they're actually
they're going to steal the gold they
don't know that it's well they don't
know what the heist is they know what it
is they just all he got he got the Udo
kir is in this too Udo in it yeah he's
the guy that gives him the lead cuz I
was like oir I'm always excited when I
see I love him but um but yeah he was
the guy that gave him the lead so the
lead was kind of nebulous so they didn't
know ex they knew that it was some kind
of big something it was a drug deal or a
big something or other and so they
didn't know what it was they just said
well there's going to be some money
exchanged and we're going to take that
money so pretty much the whole middle
part of the movie is them like just
staking out the guy these guys and like
trying to like follow them and figure
out what they're going to do so they can
intervene and like take whatever money
yeah they thought it was going to be a
drug deal but it wasn't it was a bank
robbery and they were going to steal all
this gold gold bullion yeah yeah gold
these little bars little Gold Flat bars
yeah and
um they're going to steal the gold from
the
robbers uh yeah they kind of justify it
you know is well I've been on the force
forever and we put all we we we put so
many dudes Behind Bars and look you know
they're not paying us that kind of [__]
we're eventually going to we're going to
level up we're going to steal some gold
from these we're going to steal sh we're
going to steal [__] from these robbers
and they don't know what it's going to
be it turns out it [__] be a bank
heist gold and they killed some people
during the heist yeah the not the
cops and they couldn't call it in
because they couldn't tell the cops that
they were yeah they're on suspension
yeah they were suspended they weren't
supposed to be working so they they
couldn't call it in so they just they're
like
we're on stealing these dud too so
should keep out in the middle of nowhere
and there's a big damn in the end
there's a big showdown between basically
three groups over this
gold and it's it's a good flick it's
like a Tarantino kind of
flick I don't want to spoil it but I did
like like I said I liked the realism of
this even though you could argue um you
know and I have seen this really this
seemed to get like cuz I read like a lot
of um contemporary reviews of it from
when it came out and a lot of critics
really did like this and they pointed
out um you know that like it was one of
Mel Gibson's best performances and uh
you know and [__] like that and uh they
liked kind of the darkness of it like
the themes the moral ambiguity they like
really like that um a couple of people
did complain that they thought it was
too long and that some stuff could be
trimmed out of it but I I can see that
but it didn't bother me I wasn't bored
same could be said for Pulp Fiction and
if you went and cut anything out of Pulp
Fiction people would hate you it
wouldn't be the same because it's not
the same movie yeah there's you're
supposed to enjoy it there's long scenes
in this of like I said Vince vaugh
eating a sandwich in the car there's
long scenes of them just kind of like
sitting watching these people but what
you know what I liked about that though
they're getting on each other's nerves
right like an old married couple it's
like super funny and it's just kind of
like cuz the two of them play really
well off each other cuz you know Vince
vaugh is obviously like a lot younger
yeah than Mel Gibson and so um but they
kind of have they're kind of similar but
kind of different in some ways too but
they kind of get on each other's nerves
but they do have each other's backs and
[__] I guess they've been partners for
you know however long I don't even think
they specified but I liked that I was
like you very rarely see this almost
seemed more like a 70s movie yeah I was
bullet in a certain way well I kind of
feel like as Craig Zer said the
inspiration for this was the killing the
Stanley Kubrick movie and some of the
like 7s movies like Dog Day Afternoon
like with alucino and [__] like that and
I was like yeah that's kind of what it
was reminding me of it was more like a'
70s like gritty kind of cop drama but I
liked the way cuz normally you see like
a crime Thriller and they cut out like
just a lot of random [__] so it's just
kind of like we need to get like a
gunfight or you know some exciting [__]
this one kind of shows more like what
it's really like when you're like on a
stake out or when uh a gunfight like
this happens cuz even like the big the
big uh you know confrontation like
toward the end is kind of done like in
real time it's not edited like it's this
big exciting Hollywood uh shootout or
anything like that it's more like it
would happen in real life and I kind of
dug that yeah and um
they what was I going to say about the
uh it doesn't matter doesn't matter I
forgot what I was going to say about I
was going to say something about the way
it was edited and everything yeah okay
yeah they're not they're almost actually
bored yeah during during the gunfight
because that's what a r they they had
been they you know they had been doing
this these are old guys yeah so they're
not really rattled by getting shot or
then they just jump in a car and just
Ram the other car real quick try to try
to turn a damn vehicle over and then
then they go back and you know start
shooting and stuff and just they're
chilled out about it well that's why I I
said to Tom like kind of how yeah during
the last confrontation I was like I love
how chill they are yeah like about the
situation you you can go back and you
can go back on on YouTube and look at
like combat footage from Afghanistan and
see my old unit the 101st on patrol and
when they make contact with somebody who
shot at them from a distance and they're
out there for 20 to 30 minutes shooting
down at little bushes and then talking
to each other in between yeah the
firefights and they're not scared that's
what this reminded me of they've been
doing this it seemed a lot more
realistic cuz I said you see like I said
you see footage of like real police
shootouts and stuff like that live is
just kind of like sitting around yeah
they're laying down and that's kind of
what this was like this wasn't like
super heightened emotions or you know
trying to make it like more exciting CU
it's like a movie or anything like that
they made it seem more like what it
would really be like like in that
situation and I kind of liked that yeah
because you don't usually see that in
films of this type right so I was kind
of into that yeah I thought it was good
yeah and I don't want to say that it's a
it's not a fake Tarantino flick it's
structured like a Tarantino yeah but
that's about and the dialogue is good
yeah is kind of like witty yeah and then
well
Tarantino sometimes he really Nails
dialogue yeah sometimes he's had some
weird idiosyncracies in the dialogues
though too sometimes it's just but he's
he's tried to Homage basically old
flicks and Pulp Fiction type [__] yeah
this one's a little more little bit more
realistic than that yeah this one seems
like more organic it's like I said it's
not as stylized and I like Tarantino but
it's not as stylized as Tarantino's mie
but if you like that kind of movie you'd
love this it's good one of favorite
lines in this was when they were getting
um suspended in Don Johnson's office
yeah and um and Vince Von says that he
can't be racist because he always buys a
dark roast coffee on MLK day yeah they
that [__] made me laugh it's set in a
kind of a fictional city yeah it's
called bullwark so you don't know where
it is but there it's kind of like LA or
I guess it was shot in I think it was
shot in Vancouver actually okay it's
supposed to be kind of like a parallel
universe La you're not quite you don't
really know where this is but it's just
yeah it's it's a it's a fictional city
yeah and it's goofing on I think
California uh and you know the way they
run their police departments and you
know all the [__] like PC type [__]
and they were they were
real antimodernism they these guys liked
old school [__] they do it the old the
old way and that was the reason why they
didn't get promoted yeah that you only
got promoted by kissing ass and [__]
telling the superior is what they wanted
to hear but they didn't they weren't
like that they're like ah [__] it you
know they didn't care and then there was
a whole side plot too with um Vince Von
wanting to propose to his girlfriend
yeah all kind and that was a whole side
plot too him buying the ring and
everything and his girlfriend was an
executive and just basically to his face
says I'm smarter than you and [__] and
he was still [__] going out where
they're out of dump that [__]
but smarter than you by a yard stick you
know kind although he also said that to
Gibson well she got that from him guess
he got that from her maybe
yeah she'd been saying that to him yeah
I guess so because she just saw him as a
dumb
cop Tammy said have you guys seen
Boondock Saints one or two I've seen the
first one but I haven't seen the second
one nothing that's weird about this
movie they make for a good review yeah I
agree I really liked boond another weird
thing about this movie and I think it
maybe gives it the tone this kind of
Stark realistic tone there's no there's
no score at
all not really that I remember closest
thing to a score is just that they
listen to the radio and you hear it they
react to it and ask questions about the
song and then that towards the end they
were playing that song again it kind of
like a little theme song the movie the
movie that the um I think s Craig Zer
also did um he either wrote the music
for this or he collaborated with someone
else and like wrote all the original
songs for this because there were some
other songs in it too but um the end the
the song over the end credits [__]
cracked me up because the song over the
end and credits I don't know if you
heard it cuz I think you ran to the
bathroom after but it was based on you
know that video game that was kind of
that um that the Henry slim character
was playing like the the younger tall
black guy um that he was playing with
his brother that was called like
shooting Safari or whatever it was
called where they're like shooting lions
or shotgun Safari yeah so the song was
just like the shotgun safari theme song
but it was just like the it was just
like an ' 80s it was like shotgun Safari
like it was just it was super funny so I
was like oh that's going to it was a
total earworm but um so yes two black
guys are great in in in in the movie too
and they together and yeah they end up
working for the bad guys and they
realize that the bad guys going to [__]
him over and they try to figure out how
they're going to get out of this and
then in the end they try to figure out
at least one of them tries to figure out
how they're going to get the gold and
get out of there to me it seemed like
Henry SLS slim that's what the that's
what the bank robbers called him slim
but his actual name was Henry uh who was
played by Tory KD by the way yeah um I
kind of feel like he was maybe there's
no heroes in this movie I'm not going to
say that everybody are kind of bad guys
like of one shade or another like I said
this is not it's all gray yeah this is
this is all like a very moral ambiguity
type of movie there are no good people
in this but I kind of feel like he was
the most
sympathetic yeah he was the he he did
bad [__] too but he didn't do anything
that bad though no he really didn't he
was probably the best guy out of all of
yeah I kind of feel like he was the
other two guys the cops were dirty cops
they were they terrible basically they
were and U he was he he just got out of
prison but it was for little stuff and
he was trying to help his family out and
he did keep his promise in the end yeah
his word was good yeah but Mel Gibson
character that the cops didn't know that
his word was good they didn't trust him
they they were low trust yeah which is
understandable but see that's another
thing that was kind of cool about this
movie was that as I said it was much
more like realistic in the sense that
nobody was all good or all bad everybody
even people that did like horribly
shitty things you didn't condone what
they were doing but you understood the
thought process that got them to that
place it was goal directed right it was
all goal directed like you understood
you're like well I wouldn't have done
that cuz that's a terrible thing to do
but you can understand how that person
would do that like given their
circumstances so I kind of feel like
that was that was another good thing
about the movie is that everything was
just much more like it would be in real
life well the three ninja Assassins
those guys were bad they were [__]
yeah they well they weren't I didn't
even consider them characters because
you didn't well you really only knew the
main guy's name yeah never the other
ones I think even in the credits they
were just called black gloves and gray
gloves yeah like they just went around
killing random people like just trying
to get the money like to for the to pay
for the van like to do The Big Heist you
never see their faces and you never see
them like you do see the main guy yeah
uh the European guy uh who's like you
know heading up the heist you do see
that guy but he's not you don't see
enough of him for him to be like a
character character you know what I mean
kind of he's an he he's a supporting
character yeah so and and he's and he's
definitely a bad guy he doesn't really
have any redeeming qualities at all but
like the other characters even though
they do horribly shitty things and a
couple of times like when some of the
characters did show I'm like oh man [__]
that sucks but you understand like why
they did it though and like why they
thought they had do that yeah and they
and they had justifications and the cops
were of course you know they
were the two police characters they were
kind of uh I guess you could say they
were very morally gray and breaking the
rules when it came to arresting people
and how to deal with you know [__]
suspects but then they're on this
special operations where they're going
to steal from Crooks that's illegal as
[__] and they [__] they knew exactly
what that but you know their
justification was is that uh they
weren't paying them enough that they
deserved it that for for a whole
lifetime career of good service that
they wanted that they wanted their
payoff that they yeah and it was like I
said as reprehensible as some things
that Mel Gibson's character his name was
ridgeman right that was his last name
yeah Richmond yeah richemond that's what
they called him I sympathize with him no
he was bad gu that's what I mean it's
like even though he did some
reprehensible things like [__] over
yeah you could understand like why like
if I was in that situation too I might
think doing the same kind of [__] you
know what Ian get [__] over but he was
trying to help his family out of the jam
yeah like I said they were trying to
they didn't have enough money to move he
hadn't been promoted like in all this
time and his wife was sick couldn't go
back to work yeah his wife had Ms his
wife was like a former cop yeah and she
you know could barely walk anymore and
um you know and he just wanted to
provide for them and that it's like very
understandable and you can understand
why he would be like you know [__] he
got suspended because he got because
yeah without pay because he got filmed
like doing which you know kicking in
some dude's head which you shouldn't do
obviously but um you know but he was got
mad because he's like oh that's going to
go viral and everybody's G to say this
and that so he got suspended and he
never got promoted in all those years it
was 20 something years he never got
promoted yeah because he just wouldn't
play politics yeah which like I said you
kind of have to like in every yep
position that you're in just because you
have well you have to deal with people
and dealing with people that's just what
that entails it's like I don't like it
either but you know that's what you have
to do and if you can't do that then
that's kind of where the chips fall yeah
you need to start your own business yeah
if you can't play politics but I mean
that's kind of like like us
yeah yeah but yeah so that was kind of
the position he was in so and he at this
point like in the movie he's like look
I'm like 60 years old I'm too old for
this [__] it's like I don't really give
a [__] anymore and he even gives like
Vince vaugh Who is younger he he like in
his 40s or something like that he's like
look yeah Jason was older than 60 yeah
well obviously but in the movie you know
yeah I'm like getting to retirement AG
it's like I deserve better like I've
done so much for this city and put so
many bad guys away and they haven't
rewarded me I still live in this shitty
neighborhood my wife is sick she can't
work anymore my daughter is getting
harassed every day and I'm worried that
something bad's going to happen to her
and it's like they wanted to move and
they didn't have money so he's kind of
like well I'm just going to you know
they did this to me so I'm just going to
[__] take my [__] shot and like I
said he said to Vince vaugh he's like
look you're still young you can still
get promoted you can do this that and
the other you don't have to do this with
me yeah but you know Vince Von was like
his partner and that's just kind of how
because Vince Von had his own problems
too I guess like you know he was younger
and he still had you know possibility of
him getting promoted and stuff but you
know he wanted to marry his girlfriend
it's like you know we pay for this big
wedding and all this other kind of [__]
and so he was like okay well I'm going
to back you on that too although he was
kind of wishy-washy at the beginning
he's like well he was kind of intrigued
and then he's like well I'm in till I'm
not well like I said they didn't know
exactly what they were getting into was
the thing and they just had to roll with
it as it was happening and yeah because
they didn't know exact all they had was
this tiny lead oh this guy and there's
some big thing going down like some big
money exchange like I said they thought
it was just like a drug deal and it
would just be like wham bam thank you
ma'am they would just go in there and
like steal the money and it would be
fine but it turned out that it was like
much bigger than that and then like once
they were kind of embroiled in it they
sort of had to like see it through to
that and um let's I don't think it's too
much of a spoiler alert to say well the
[__] goes badly the [__] goes badly so
um but uh but yeah and honestly some
sequences in this were really really
stressful to watch because the cool
thing about this movie too is that you
never know exactly how shit's going to
happen so there's like a lot of the
scenes like particularly like the scene
toward the end where they're you know
having the big uh confrontation like
over the gold and everything or even
like the scene before that like with two
black eyes like driving the van and it's
like cuz there there's just like this
tension in the air because you never
know when some bad shit's going to go
down cuz sometimes you know somebody
just gets [__] shot out of nowhere
yeah no warning also um for fans of bone
Tomahawk and you know that that movie
was just kind of like a pretty languid
kind of like cool Western and then at
the end it just goes like super gory
this has it's not this one's not as gory
is that but I will note that if you're
squeamish it does have one scene where a
dude is cut open and something is cut
out of his stomach so yeah it didn't
show much though but it didn't show much
of it not like bone Tomahawk which if
you haven't seen bone Tomahawk yeah that
was a good
movie that was something that was a trip
that scene was like really something
like I've like I've seen it's not the
worst thing I've ever seen but um it was
pretty bad it was pretty bad this isn't
that bad but thinking about it is pretty
gross it doesn't show as much and it's
kind of in the dark but you can still
kind of tell what's going on but it's
kind of a similar kind of situation you
know what I
mean um Zach says to me this movie
seemed like a weird Halfway House of
like something a big Studio would put
out and a24 would make it did kind of
seem to be like on the cusp
of yeah like a like a Hollywood movie
but then like an art House Hollywood
movie kind of well like I said more
really good Indie flip more like from
the 70s like you would have seen like
from a from kind of like a like an aour
director in the 70s I kind of feel like
it had that vibe to it yeah it's a it's
a little it's it's it's a gem yeah you
know and I feel like it's really
underrated like I when it first came out
I remember there being like a little bit
of hype around it um but you know I
think it just got a real limited like
theatrical release like before it went
to no this was no way a [__] big
Hollywood tent pole type this this is
this like I said it's almost three hours
long yeah it's like a 70s cop drama [__]
no and a lot of it is just like people
hanging around talking you know what I
mean but it's fascinating like the
dialogue is really good yeah and kind of
hardboiled
yeah but there's a lot of movies like
this that you know were excellent people
forgot about like the like the gangster
uh flick Gloria you never even heard of
it yeah that that's a great flip watch
watch that didn't we I don't know I
think we did yeah I think we did yeah
yeah Gloria was kind of like the
original version of damn professional
yeah yeah or yeah the professional kind
of like a reverse of that yeah older
woman trying to take care of a little
boy she's a gangster yeah guys are
everybody the mobs trying to kill him
good flick very New York very very New
York old New York yeah which I like
movies that are set in like yeah the old
scuzzy New York yeah shootouts in public
yeah inside restaurant
hundreds of people watching it and
they're out there shooting and you can
tell it filmed on location well yeah
they filmed a lot of [__] back then
that's why I that's why I like all those
movies like that like um you know like
Abel ferer Ferrera made and um all that
kind of stuff like all that weird old
[__] like basket case and all that kind
of stuff cuz like I like that old scuzzy
like New York Vibe yeah this kind of has
that but it's not New York it has more
of a California feel like a la it does
yeah even though like I said it was shot
in Lao kind of feel well those those are
very different places yeah I thought it
was supposed to be happening in like a
parallel universe La yeah kind of
possibly it's hard yeah it's hard to
tell I mean I guess if you're from
Vancouver you'd be like oh hey I know
where that is but um you know I've never
been to Vancouver so I don't know but
that's where they shot it they shoot a
lot of movies there actually cheaper
yeah it is yeah they shoot a lot of
movies in Toronto also yeah Toronto
stands in for New York City Philadelphia
pretty much any big city Toronto stands
in for that [__] cuz it's like so it's
cheaper to film in Canada uh Tammy says
Vince vaugh is great in that serial
killer movie I can't remember the name
of it oh I know which one you're talking
about what [__] movie was that I saw
it it was it was really good [__] now I
can't remember either he's actually it's
so funny because Vince vaugh I think the
first movie I saw him in was [__]
swingers with John favro the dude that
does the Marvel movies you know what I
mean um or the Star Wars [__] and um
yeah it's it's just fun like how far
they've come but Vince vaugh he was he's
actually a good actor when he's given
like good material I really don't like
that he was in that [__] I don't see
the point of that [__] Gus Van like
psycho shot for shot remake that he was
in he played Norman Bates in that it
wasn't a terrible movie it's just I
didn't really see the point of it what
is the point of remaking
psycho exactly like the first one except
in color because it's with different
actors because it's in color now it was
shot for shot yeah and I'm just like
yeah I mean do what you want like it
like it's an artistic medium I'm not
going to get too mad about it but I'm
just kind of like I don't know I don't
see the point of redoing something that
close to the original especially
something like psycho which is like such
a classic I don't really get it like I
said if you're going to remake something
if I was going to remake something if
somebody said here's $50 million I wish
um you know let's remake something I
would remake something that was like
kind of sucked the first time but was
like a good idea you know what I mean I
was like that that's a good idea but it
wasn't executed that well because they
didn't have enough money or the actors
blew or whatever it's just kind of like
so I would try to like do it right the
second time don't take something that
was perfect the first time and try to
like make it better because you're not
going to you know just spoiler alert um
Zach says apparently Vancouver is going
to stand in first Seattle when they
start shooting Last of Us season Here
season two here soon yeah like I said
they film a lot of [__] in Vancouver and
Toronto because
it's just generic big city you know what
I mean
um Camp guy said Brian Dene was in a
John Wayne gasy
movie now that I'm thinking about that
that's actually kind of perfect casting
Brian Dan he does kind of look like John
casy a little
bit um Tammy said ever see Fred Claus
Vince plays Santa's brother I did not
see that that does not look like the
title of a movie that I would watch but
maybe maybe I'd watch it I was going to
say something else too about um oh
because you said something about the
last of us so we did actually watch the
first episode of the new Walking Dead
spin-off Daryl Dixon it was pretty good
it was actually pretty good I liked it
I'm gonna buy the whole season like kind
of a it's I liked that they went kind of
in a different direction with it if you
don't like at the beginning I'm not
going to spoil it because it just came
out but um but Daryl I didn't see like
the we haven't seen The Walking Dead in
a long time so I don't know like what
happened like leading up to this cuz I
think the last couple Seasons we didn't
see them but he just basically washes up
on some [__] beach in France
somewhere yeah he was strapped to the
bottom of a Dy yeah upside down what
yeah I guess he got thrown off a ship or
something and um and so the whole thing
is just so I was like I like that I like
that they kind of transplanted it over
to like a completely different contr a
completely different setting like it's
got this medieval and there's like a
nunnery and [__] I'm like that's kind of
cool they have a new religion yeah
that's kind of cool I like I thought it
was a good idea so you know it it might
suck as it goes on I don't know but I
thought the first episode was actually
really good and actually wanted it sell
the whole season for 10 bucks yeah so we
might actually end up watching that
gonna gonna see Expendables 4 too
probably Friday yeah I think yeah
because I think that starts yeah I think
it starts on Friday yeah so we're going
to go see Expendables for it now do I
need to have seen the first three no
you've seen the first three I no I've
seen the first one did I see the second
one yeah I think so I don't remember a
single [__] thing about it I really
don't don't matter it doesn't matter
yeah I feel like it's not this is not
like a think piece it's not like I
really have to be like like who is this
now right who's going to be in this one
everybody everybody yeah I don't know
they didn't really say not Steven seal
though no they asked him he wouldn't go
oh he wouldn't come but Chuck Norris is
Chuck Norris in it no oh that's right no
more Chuck cuz they were like get the
hell off our movie CH you non swearing
[__] Chuck won't let
swear that's why Expendables 3 I can
never hang out Expendables 3 um
theatrical release isn't any good but if
you get the Blu-ray and watch the
directors cut it's real good it has all
the [__] that Chuck moris made
cut why they why does anybody listen to
Chuck anymore I think it was three it's
either three or
two we'll have to [__] watch that I
actually like three the best a lot of
people didn't like it three had Antonio
Banderas in it okay see I didn't see
that one we'll see three you probably
seen two huh I think what happens in the
second one I forgot I forgot he forgot
to mer stuff I I know I saw the first
one cuz you showed me the first one you
might have shown me the second one but I
don't remember I think I think I showed
you the second one okay well we can
watch I think like the third one the the
third one the best probably the third
one's
good the director's cut we can watch it
tonight if you want okay Tammy said uh I
love the new Walking Dead Daryl is such
a great character so she's talk about
the Daryl Dix yeah the Daryl Dixon one
so I guess she's seen more than one
episode of it yeah I don't really I
don't know how long it's been out
because I just remember like seeing ads
for it recently but that doesn't mean
anything problem with The Walking Dead
was is like you know after season 4 or
so the writing went went to [__] it
wasn't realistic they started to try to
Homage the comic books too much and a
lot of that [__] did not [__] work in
live action yeah a lot of it was just
kind of too silly yeah silly you said
like the weird ant people ant people and
people with tigers and [__]
[__] that might have worked in a comic
book but that doesn't work in real life
the first like four seasons the first
four seasons of The Walking Dead um were
great that was great survival
Adventure lessons you know [__] you
had to be hardcore to live in it then
they decided to well we have to have
like people that are from our audience
like they in the zombie apocalypse and
they can survive too no catastrophes are
evolutionary bottlenecks most of the
people die first because of the way they
are the only people that survive is
because of the way they are and in a
situation like that they'd all be
psychos pretty much that psychos that
could work together remember the claim
guys the guys that walk around just
claim [__] yeah that's actually
realistic that's that's like some [__]
that that they would do just a bunch of
crazy dudes running around saying that's
mine I claim that and then they would
just rape and kill people basically
there'd be a lot of that those dudes
reminded me of like you know when your
little brother you used to like go in
the refrigerator and there'd be a
cupcake and then he would lick it and
put it back back you'd be total [__]
total [__] because they you know
they would have been bums they would
have started off as bums basically you
know people that already had survival
skills they could just sleep outside and
live off of nothing they they'd have a
lot better chance of surviving because
they've been
survived and it got it gets easier for
them because now there's stuff that they
could just pick up and use
use so and then there'd be like you know
what was his name the governor's Camp
yeah you see stuff like that living in
living in the prison remember when they
lived in the prison you'd see that kind
of stuff right but you wouldn't see ant
people yeah it's already to get a little
silly after that like these weird like
communities they kept it's like look
these are all the people that were like
all the Ren festers and they're like
yeah wouldn't happen they have a king
and they're riding horses and stuff I'm
like yeah I just don't think that would
happen you see you see massive
motorcycle
gags and if they couldn't get fuel
they'd all be on BMX bikes cuz that
would be good too people don't realize
that bicycles were the replacement for
horses that some of them some of the
[__] that they make Now is better than a
horse you don't have to feed it yeah I
think if a zombie apocalypse happened
I'd be getting myself a bicycle and a
big [__] sword saddle bags a backpack
yep I'm one of those [__] 12 speed I
can think a 12 speed don't need no ammo
it's got Vaseline don't need no nothing
yeah like turbo kid bike breaks down you
just get another one they had BMX bikes
in a turbo kit they did yeah and it was
like post-apocalyptic turbo kid is also
great if you haven't seen it I think it
might be on 2B actually I think it's
Australian Australian or or uh might
might be New Zealand but uh you
know Jack the mcau said Tom needs his
own mic yeah what that sound far away
well you shouldn't sound that far away
it's just it's it's right there yeah
it's like and he talks loud yeah so I
don't really know I can when he talks
downstairs I can hear him all the way up
here yeah Tammy says uh there are two
episodes so far of the Daryl Dixon show
plus a joob bob Brig special uh really
okay so if you buy the season you only
get to see uh the episodes as they come
out yeah that's what I'm saying I
thought it was new out so that's why
when they were saying oh you can buy the
season I must I was like that must be a
pre-order
deal because I'm like pretty sure that
the whole season isn't out yet so it's
not like back in the day you buy the
season you can just binge watch the
whole season in a night right well well
yeah because it's just kind of like we
watched the first one they offer the
first one for free on AMC plus yeah but
after that like you got to pay you know
what I mean so we just like bred it on
that because we don't have AMC
plus Zach says uh when my dad watches
the Colts you can hear him screaming all
the way from the other side of the
house that's what [__] hilarious yeah
uh yeah and Tammy said that's why Daryl
does so well he was a redneck from
Georgia yeah and he's not a big fan of
like having to be around people you know
what I mean yeah he's like got
some you know some deep down emotions
and [__] like that but it's like he's
okay by himself he didn't even know how
to use the internet yeah remember that
he he he used newspapers that's right
yeah that's really funny but yeah I'm
just I you know I'm I'm curious to see
where they're going to go with it
because it almost seems like they have
him on it's almost like a weird like
Messiah Quest kind of like he's not the
Messiah but they're kind they kind of
look like they're setting that up so but
like I said I'm kind of interested to
see how it's going to go like it's
almost like this medieval they have like
all these old like um convents and [__]
like that like in France and it's like
pretty cool and Tom said well that's
maybe how they got uh Norman Reus to do
this he's like hey we'll shoot it in
Europe and you get to stay over there
for free all this time and get paid he's
like okay sign me up I don't blame
him okay um Brian's actually watching
live but he can't comment for some
reason I don't know why oh I wonder why
there's been some people that have said
that it's not like you're blocked or
banned nobody is blocked on here so it's
not it's not on our end I'm not really
sure what's going on we heard that if
you uh if if that sometimes YouTube will
censor people for because they they made
comments on videos or in other live
chats that they didn't like so they can
mute you
and I mean I don't think it's you sucks
man I don't think it's just swearing
because I see people swear sometimes and
they don't get no it's not swearing it's
just uh it's political it's political if
you say anything against the ruling
classes you're they're going to go after
you well I'm yeah because I wondered if
he was going to you know if he was going
to watch this one because I said you
know like I said he worked on this movie
so and he's been wanting to do this for
a long time we finally we finally
watched it we finally watched it yeah he
sent me a message on messenger saying
he's watching now oh okay that's good
yeah but yeah yeah I really dug this
movie to be honest with you um I didn't
think it was too long I thought it was I
was just intrigued all the way through
all the characters were good all the
characters were
interesting and I don't know I just I
just thought it was like the he's got
like Craig Zer like has his own thing
going on man and I kind of like what he
has going on because he doesn't really
seem to give a [__]
about um you know standard movie
structure or anything like that he's
just
I saw somebody and actually I thought
this was a pretty s du comment I saw
somebody describe this movie that's like
that's almost like a novel but in movie
form and it does kind of play out like
that it plays out more like a book than
a movie I think it'll be a classic yeah
I definitely think this is maybe one
that needs some time to right simmer and
Word of Mouth kind of thing and then
like later on I was watching a thing by
by like a um a film professor earlier
who really liked this movie and he was
talking about how underrated it was and
he was talking about the themes and uh
you know in quite in-depth he said one
of the main themes of this um he said
which is pointed out in a lot of uh
imagery of lions and stuff is predation
like people praying on other people yeah
and um and everyone praying on each
other so like all the [__] he pointed
out was like really uh was really
observant I thought but yeah there is
like a lion imagery in this like the
video game and [__] like that um Zach
says oh who's the film Professor uh that
sounds really cool are they a YouTuber
yeah but I can't [__] remember the
name of it it's one of the there's not a
huge amount of reviews of this um but so
if you put in dragged across concrete
review he's kind of like a bald guy what
the [__] is the name of that channel
I've seen his other like um breakdowns
of it I think it's only like 13 minutes
but it's like a a pretty good uh
breakdown of like the themes of the
movie and stuff like that yeah hack is
saying that he definitely has unpopular
opinions so yeah they won't they won't
let you talk dude you've been
silenced oh [__] almost dropped that on
pooky's head oh no Po's like oh [__]
Daddy yeah yeah she ran okay it was an
accident it was an accident daddy didn't
mean it and then she looked at you daddy
daddy didn't mean it it's okay I have to
tell him that all the time daddy didn't
mean it uh Zach says I think you guys
might like that Kate Blanchette movie
tar by the way it's kind of a horror
movie too yeah I've been hearing about
that I might uh end up watching that one
of these days one of these days um but
yeah oh Tammy said uh Greg nicera was on
the Joe Bob special and he also said
yeah Reus wanted to film in Paris right
yeah well does Norman hope they got good
Riders does Norman Reus still do that
motorcycle show I don't know I used to
like that actually yeah he seems like a
cool dude he's he's pretty chill like
going around meeting people like riding
around on his bike I don't know if he's
still doing that or not I don't know
either like because we don't watch cable
anymore um but yeah all right so we are
going to wrap it up so hopefully you
guys can drop by on Wednesday evening
for our main show we're going to be
talking about some more True Crime we're
going to be talking about a [__] up
serial killer again who I feel is maybe
not all that well known anymore uh his
name is Tony Costa also known as the
Cape Cod vampire I don't know that one
yeah I think a lot of people don't um
but you know okay he did some uh pretty
[__] up [__] Cape Cog vampire I'm I'm
actually reading a book about him at the
moment uh on my Kindle
unlimited it's called Helltown so uh
we're gonna get into that too uh yeah
because it's it's a pretty messed up
story so I think one of you guys maybe
recommended it because I hadn't heard of
him either but now that I'm reading him
like this was also in the 60s like late
60s so we're getting back into that all
right so hopefully you guys enjoyed the
show this evening and hopefully you guys
can join us again on Wednesday night uh
thanks for dropping by and we'll see you
guys again on Wednesday good